hello and welcome to this video
after my vacation break i'm back on
with some daily blitz videos
um please let me know if everything is
fine technically i
tried to do something during my vacation
make a video there and there's always a
bit of a
risk like screwing up settings
because um that would be then integrated
camera
and other microphone and so on and
i'm not totally certain that everything
is
back to yeah what it was before when i
felt the setup was good okay so
let's play this game it's a blitz game
three plus two
um against mac
engineer
right um i have looked at this line
but not totally
i cannot quite remember
how it worked nice deep this is that
at the position where that db5 is good
there is one position where this is
good i'll play it and see what happens
bishop e6's um not clear to me
but then e5 right i think i'm i'm on the
right
track here that this is the position
where i'm
knight db5 is good
yeah i think it is um yeah i'm currently
working on the
c4 knight f3 repertoire for adjustable
the lifetime
repertoire and
this is always a process um
yeah i mean what i try to say is you
look at
all kinds of variations and
until everything is kind of
close to finished i only have a sketchy
knowledge of everything of course some
of the lines
that are in this repertoire i've played
before it's not all
new to me but the
the line here the fiance king's indian
in this particular
type of opening i have not studied
before
so i have to remember
things and in some cases i haven't even
looked at it
yet i mean i know what what's going to
be in the repertoire
but if not
done a really detailed study yeah
i'm thinking about this move trying to
use the d5 square
white seems to be quite a bit better
here anyway
i have the bishop here in a very nice
near control over everything bishop c6
also was a strong move probably
okay black is simply not caring at all
is that really so easily possible so if
i take b6 that's rook b8 yeah that is um
his claim okay if i play b3
and simply wait
knight b6 rook b8
hm
yeah i can't do ob3 though i mean how
does he save this pawn
knight d6 there's a rook d6s97 check
he has rook b8 but that is extremely
passive
still now maybe
i have to keep in mind that this is
increment that's really important
i have played mostly non-increment
during my vacation i played a good
number of blitz games but it was um
usually without an increment
well that is it's really not so good
i overestimated
my chances here making bishop takes f6
probably not such a great idea
giving up that really strong bishop pair
only
yeah it should have a very concrete
immediate benefit otherwise it should
not be done okay
let's try to attack here on the light
squares but he is a little bit weak
but he's strong on the dark squares
knight six
stuff like that knight e3
is probably going to play f4
okay let's go f3
and attack his pawn on e4
i still think i'm somewhat better but
i was a lot a lot better before
and this is not nothing's fantastic i
think what i have here
yeah 44 seconds it's not ideal but again
with the increment
it's not very worrisome
interesting okay
so i think i'm taking this and now what
knight f4 i'm not sure where i'm getting
with this
maybe i get out of checks on dark
squares
it's a bit a bit of a bit of a lazy move
i'm a little bit influenced by the time
situation here i'm trying to
simplify simplified a little bit which
is probably not objectively best
all right e3 huh
got knight d3 coming
[Music]
hmm
let's see one coming it's really
annoying
wow now that was really a huge misplay
this whole game
the position right of the opening was
absolutely fantastic for white
wouldn't be surprised if the engine
finds a straight win
i mean it would be actually what i would
expect
to happen
very annoying really
but maybe this is um not so bad this
regrouping now the check is threatened
okay
yeah he will definitely play on i would
do the same for sure
really really tough to do anything
constructive here with white
rook g2 maybe bishop e2 would be maybe a
good regrouping
this one okay then he's got knights you
want
that's not good
couldn't really figure this out
that is an annoying loss very very
annoying loss
[Music]
yeah yeah that's really really i mean it
was more or less i think a winning
position
out of the opening like here this is
just
awful for black but it's probably like a
plus two position
yeah yeah it is plus plus two i'm kind
of close to that
and bishop c6 is really um yeah
i mean it's just just totally awful
he has to go back here or whatever and
then he's just stuck with all those
weaknesses
bishop g5 is not as strong as it looked
yeah this this is not really that great
because
taking on b6 doesn't really do much
now e4 i didn't even see i was just
thinking rook b8 is enough
which is actually probably still an
advantage actually if i look at this now
here 97 is better for white right
yeah like this is better for white
because here i have bishop d5
yeah which is really good
so then i should probably still take
here i mean okay the engine
gives e4 but this is still better
than what um what i did probably
because here nothing much is going on
i still think i'm better here but not
not much i guess yeah
yeah it's indeed the engine says about
equal
and i lost the threat then with little
time on the clock
like somewhere here
yeah yeah that was a game that i
totally lost and he did not win in a way
particular out of the opening that was
pretty awful
like here yeah bishop g5
that was too superficial
yeah in particular because it's pretty
clear that if i just keep it as it is
it's it's really fantastic
and this is this is very very good for
wine
okay after that it's difficult i should
probably take on b6
this is something that i feel um should
be played
even though e4 seems to give like pretty
reasonable play
i'm still not totally sure why honestly
so b3 what does the engine want to do it
takes
and e3 okay hmm
yeah maybe but
i'd still rather be white here that
doesn't look like the most convincing
compensation
even though if the computer gives it as
roughly equal
it's probably the case they are not
really wrong
in those situations but
i would still be reasonably happy with
this position having this pawn
yeah mostly i should avoid bishop g5
this is
yeah i was tempted by this immediate
idea to take and or play knight d5
and gain material then there's nothing
really i shouldn't play for material
here because if it just stays how it is
the position is
more or less winning itself okay guys
thanks for watching